das volk hätte bisher einzige hipster
der metal hört dadurch bis jetzt noch
ein größerer hitze
und schüler vz schülervz hat ja keine
ahnung also packen wir das thema ein
fachbeitrag kräften haben ich habe noch
zwei ist aber auch komische jungs teil
diesmal bitte eure meinung dass spotify
mit ist das jetzt sehr gut oder eher
schlecht marcel jacobs ich weiß es kam
nicht so gute themen an
doch weil ich selbst hab es aber erstmal
möchte ich dass wir anfangen das portal
zu bauen weil sonst bei ihren fans
wieder dabei hier mit anderen sag ich
ausführlich was die spotify ja wo bist
du denn hier
ich würde sagen warte kommen wir haben
hier eine menge platz da wird sich aber
keiner hin weil es einfach nur eine
freifläche ist okay das ist irgendwie
bis hin zu fett für ein portal wie kann
sich wirklich irgendwie noch einer hin
bauen
jetzt müssen wir stehen auf einmal
obsidian blöcke in der landschaft
schuldet und ich schüttele spotify ja
okay das portico und du siehst ja
zentral lasst uns das hier hin packen
man steht direkt hier mittendrin auf
sondererhebung ich finde wir packen das
in das haus von minecraft back nine
behindert in dem bunker ist es der
bunker eine poker sachen sex wir können
auch hier so wie kann das ja hier in
machen hier sind hier gut youtube
nein das ist dann das haus von links
verdeckt und hier ist auch so nah an der
farm ist hier nicht so schön und so nahm
bunker ich will niemand hin
nexteer speziellen bamm bamm bamm bamm
und zwar war ich genau mehr zeit als auf
spotify ist für alle das heißt auch dass
wir wirklich alles erklären müssen naja
ich beispiel sowie mich doch ich kenne
ich hab mir facebook
der code auf das sieht man ja meine
leiste rechts hier ändert ich lese ist
listening to fly solo bis kaliber und
spotify bewertet dass mein bruder oder
so eine schwere aber es steht nicht
gerade lustig naja spotify ist eine
musik streamingdienst scheiße mich
vertraut geht man drei jahre geht man 2
1 2 und verbaut
na ja weil es beim thema bleiben
spotify ist ein musik streamingdienst
sage ich mal
naja jedenfalls hat man die möglichkeit
sich mit seinem facebook account oder
anzumelden kann man dort kostenlos musik
ziemlich ziemlich sehr geilen qualität
in der besten qualität die ich je gehört
habe online und sind wirklich die ganzen
also ziemlich viele ziemlich viele user
gehen immer mehr auf spotify dazu sage
ich mal
man kann jetzt zum beispiel also immer
mehr man kann immer mehr musik von immer
mehr interpreten bei spotify hören die
qualität ist sehr gut und es gibt dann
halt diese möglichkeit als das alles
kostenlos allerdings gibt es die
möglichkeit weil dort natürlich auch
werbeeinblendungen und
werbeunterbrechungen sind mit filmen
werbe stimmen und bilder musik und
reiter gibt es die möglichkeit auf
spotify premium abzudecken das heißt das
upgraden dass man dann keine werbung
mehr hat und dafür dass dann auch alles
auf dem handy hören kann und so und ja
man redet quasi ab und kriegt dafür muss
im monat bezahlen dafür dass man da dann
musiker und dann kostenlos also spotify
an sich ganz gut finde ich sehr gut
ergänzen beziehungsweise korrigieren was
zu dem was du gesagt hast beste qualität
ist ihm je gehört hat
es gibt aber das ist schon mal jetzt
rein technisch gesehen falsch weil man
als nicht premium benutzer nicht da hat
man die kultur dort mit ogg vorbis
sondern sich um ein bisschen bisschen
ist ein effizienterer codec als mp3 aber
das ist doch nicht viel zur sache aber
nicht premium benutzer mit 160 kilobit
pro sekunde
heißt das es einfach wie viele ja wie
das sagt aus wie wie groß die datei wird
die musikdatei und damit ist die
qualität also je größer je mehr kilobits
pro sekunde etwas hat desto besser die
qualität zb mp3 als 192 erkennt das
vielleicht schlechte musik verbinden
warum youtube runtergeladen schlechter
qualität irgendwas 320 kilobit und in
besserer qualität als bestes 1 320 was
im 3 angeht und natürlich gibt's auch
unkomprimiert flac und so weiter was man
alles gibt aber nur als premium benutzer
hat man bei spotify obwohl bis 320
kilobit pro sekunde und da sich wollt
ihr doch noch ein deutliches stück
besser als als non premium benutzer und
ich setze strege kauft ernsthaft
ernsthaft und sa 10 euro im monat
unbegrenzt musik man hat sie auch im el
auf seinem handy als auf android oder
apple ist eine app aber es wie normale
music player dann hat man immer das
interessiert mich jetzt musste dann im
internet seien wieder die musik was mit
deinem handy lädt am anderen runterladen
die sind dann codiert auf dem handy das
so sie denn nur damit abspielen kann man
das auch mit handy runterladen regel
also nur mit einem ios gerät also aber
kann man mit handy runterladen muss man
nicht mit pc herunterladen und dann das
ganze im wlan runterladen kann also es
ist halt finde das richtig geil ehrlich
gemacht qualität als nicht bringen
benutzt ist auch schon relativ gute
qualität aber das noch nicht die beste
so definitiv besser als bei youtube das
kann so aus weil natürlich musik
optimierten
importieren kann aber wenn man auf hd
hoch lässt dann kommt ihr auf youtube
mit weiß nicht was sie da haben für
korrekt aber mit 192 kilobit man nicht
mal gelesen zu haben
aber gut das eine andere sache die
wahrscheinlich die meisten nicht mal
nicht mal am rande interessiert leider
das alles ganz einfach mal so überhaupt
nichts sagen weil ich nicht benutzt wenn
ich musik sucht dann gehe ich eher auf
pay-tv weil die so ein bisschen mehr
metal angehaucht sind das thema obst
gates dem o2 germany ist der erste metal
ipsa den ich kenne der hipster er hat
nur die underground metalbands diese
mainstreams voll da hätte ich deine
blöde einzige hipster der metal hört
dadurch bis jetzt noch ein größerer
hipster trainer muss mainspitze
gefährtin youtube auf denen steht drauf
mitteln for life underground
jack ist oh ja ich bin auch spotify
nicht zum suchen von musik sondern das
hat komplett gibt es erst seit zwei
monaten drei monaten vielleicht komplett
mein musikkonsum gewandelt so zu sagen
weil ich nur noch über spotify ein pc
spotify oder spotify das machst du jetzt
eine spitzhacke tschuldigung mpc höre
ich nur noch über spotify am handy als
er begreift der welt nur noch über
spotify viele remix ist oder so haben es
einfach nicht wie man bei youtube findet
ja aber die remixe kannst du dir
natürlich dann in zweifel kannst du dir
immer noch normal kaufen runterladen
whatever cabanas 24 die ganz normalen
länger sind ja aber die sind dann
eingebettet in spotify alles was auf
deinen pc so was den eingebetteten
spotify und die kannst du dir auch auf
den hingegen runterladen
das geile ist ja ich packe ja aber ich
verstehe man kann genauso gut auch die
ganzen anderen lieder auch einfach
genauso runterladen und er auch einfach
zwei schafe gibt ja dafür pro lied ein
euro zahlen
du kannst illegal machen aber da machen
wir vielleicht gar nicht erst reden aber
im bett wenn ich für zehn euro im monat
grenzenlos der grenzenlos also wirklich
praktisch alles was man so hören möchte
bekomme dann ist das genial für zehn
euro im monat alle musik als und es ja
es ist ja wie man hier noch deckenhöhe
egal alles ja komplett legal mir alle
lizenzen dieser brauchen und die ab die
künstler bekommen ja auch das geld dann
von spotify wasser künstler wirklich von
haben die künstler bekommen davon ganz
normal ihr geld erst mal die frage was
ganz normales ob das wirklich so viele
dieser bekommen und ihre platte kaufst
oder so weh aber ich hätte ihre platten
sonst nie gekauft
das ist ja der unterschied also ich habe
mir noch nie musikalbum auf cd gekauft
ich hab mir irgendwann mal als weil sie
nicht zwölf jahre alt war da so denn der
wohl gewünscht zu weihnachten und es
kann aber ansonsten ich habe mir eine cd
gekauft der durch hat zu einer reduktion
paar songs gekauft auf news amazon
itunes nicht weil ich habe ja nie apple
gerät benutzt darum habe ich gar keine
berührung mit uns sondern amazon finde
ich eigentlich ganz cool store für apple
geräte also wenn man apple rät so
benutzt sicherlich sinnvoll
ich hatte doch irgendwann feuerzeug na
ja aber ich bezahl sozusagen 120 euro im
jahr für mit meinen musikern sowie
spotify vielleicht kaufe ich noch hier
und da ab und zu was aber auf jeden fall
120 euro sicher im jahr für musik und da
ich unterstütze sozusagen alle künstler
dies gibt 120 euro verteilt je nachdem
wie viel ich gehör bekommen die sonst so
viel also
dass man kann es nicht sagen dass wir
schlecht für die künstler ist wer gibt
schon 120 euro heutzutage noch für musik
im jahr aus ja das würde argument